[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and
judging by that very self-aware opening
credits sequence I can take a wild guess
what we're gonna review today it looks
like we're gonna take a look at Deadpool
- yeah I'm Deadpool a Deadpool
I'm Deadpool I love to read and as you
probably figured out that means we have
to put up with asshole cosplay Deadpool
that guy at every convention who thinks
he's really funny because he has the
Deadpool cosplay but he's really just an
annoying dick
Deadpool I'm Deadpool not a review of my
movie holy shit that's right as close as
our budget will allow oh how close
decent costume clever writing
good-looking guy underneath oh okay you
know honest trailers get Ryan Reynolds
oh wow you're right well why don't you
use your clout with the crossover you
deal with them to get Reynolds well I
mean they did pull on his trailer get
over 20 million views the one you did
with them got Wow
almost three see your point I mean with
a connection that close you surely must
be able to work your charm and magic you
have no idea but connections I have so
let's get this podcast with sketches
started I assume you want to talk about
my impact on r-rated comic book movies
box-office growth and groundbreaking
fourth wall humor in the same sentence
well not so fast don't double your The
Lion King everybody's Kimba the White
Lion
hey where did quantum leap come from it
isn't he supposed to be white apparently
it wasn't pc enough so I got a black
Morty from another dimension
I'm the woke version you're as well cos
his style of comedy does it explain why
you look like Krusty the drunk that
brown well as a completely different
person I think you look very sty
judge appalled ac/dc what the hell are
you doing in my review you think you're
this big ground breaker and you're not
there's other r-rated comic book hits
other r-rated comedy hits and literally
hundreds of fourth wall breakers before
you know Kanye West of gimmicks
pretending not to begin I knew a kanye
joke it's about time some was brave
enough to make fun of him
I don't know Rick I don't think we
should piss this guy off don't worry
black Morty he's just upset because the
mass comic nailed this schtick light
years before he did I'm not afraid of
him I'm afraid of his fan base you said
what an awkward barrel of insanity that
can be I am
unicorn olia I need TP for my bunghole
because of the clothes ball Deezy Deezy
I get it now I can agree that every
fanbase has a small percent of crazies I
think you know this more than most Oh
God no idea what you mean hey fans did
you know that Rick really likes the
honey mustard sauce at Burger King Oh
every Burger King in America ambushed by
the pimply corpses of human dignity your
miserable Merc no fast-food
establishment should ever have to go
through that kind of Anarchy twice I'm
just saying that for a scientist you
should know that a small percent even if
it's a big small percent is still not
the majority so be fair you have to have
a high IQ to understand Rick and me okay
you're right every fanbase has a few bad
apples that's not the majority
that doesn't mean you're still not a
one-trick unicorn I mean what the hell
are you even supposed to be Slenderman
interviewing to be the kool-aid guy
actually why are you doing a review on
him critic I admit that's a good
question people have clearly moved on to
complaining about solo well maybe
because Deadpool is such an interesting
phenomenon it's true there have been
successful films that done what Deadpool
has done something about the way
Deadpool is presented and makes it
strangely unique based on the comic book
character created in 1991 the pool got a
following is one of the few Marvel comic
book characters to be aware he's a
Marvel comic book character he was
foul-mouthed violin funny as hell and
constantly broke the fourth wall but
again we've seen characters like this
before so what makes him not only such a
long-lasting hit but worthy of such a
dedicated following what is he doing
with his fourth wall breaking that sets
him apart from other fourth wall
breakers gee I don't know could it be
marketing the persona of an antihero who
acts like a kindergartner but with a
team of underpaid writers that
successfully convinced us they wouldn't
want to punch him in the face
hypocrite says blow me blow me too drunk
for that one let's take a look at what
makes Deadpool so unique he's not this
is Deadpool too it opens with Deadpool
as an assassin for hire who all really
blown the budget on this one aren't you
what it's a decent looking city
yeah I'm clearly on top of a building
all one of three dimensions are clearly
being explored here good buddy I wonder
how far this ball can go what do you
think four five rooftops I can bounce it
off of
oh no an invisible force field
impenetrable too bad King you have two
years to make your movies we have two
weeks oh why couldn't I be in a freddy
wong video just start killing people
compliance fix up bad guys all over the
world mostly for trailers father but hey
you got a sub this picture it comes home
to his girlfriend Vanessa from the last
movie okay this can't be over going with
you we'll take your shitty makeup like a
man you sound like a toddlers and Chiara
parents act happy Anniversary baby that
is literally my surprise you mean yes I
want to be preggers great yeah
everything's going so good and we're so
happy and we can think of baby names I'm
gonna die what I am totally gonna die no
girlfriend is this happy in the
beginning of a movie without dying first
of all it's a fourth wall breaking to me
because only I seem to be able to do
that okay second that's like the oldest
trope in the book you really think that
writers is talented you ready shout
aren't you Bob know who's responsible
for this it was me
typical Middle Eastern European American
gangster choke you killed my only love
now I'm gonna destroy you in the most
horrific way possible hey what are you
going to do combat at the pizza face to
be fair I probably could have put more
thought to that the credits roll as they
emphasize what a big deal it is that
they killed off Deadpool's one and only
true love from the last film Rick am i
dumb ass or has that been done a lot yes
to which question yes what are you
talking about we killed off the romantic
lead that's a big ass deal maybe 30
years ago but especially for a comic
book character that's not particularly
uncommon you should replace those hand
job credits you're giving yourself with
all the other movie sequels that did the
exact same thing
you know what we didn't want a home
alone to this so we weren't a different
kind of story
I don't know the idea of Deadpool being
a dad kind of sounds interesting your
inability to comprehend this key
demographic astounds me Morty
Deadpool to the days of acting like a
basement dweller whose contrived
environment rewarded Hill with ninja
moves and getting laid are gone now the
hot chick is pregnant he's raising a
baby and he has to learn the
responsibilities of being an adult
pre-order through the roof baby I know
you seem to think these movies are only
made for angry awkward overweight
fourteen-year-old boys and I give it
more credit than that ya give art a
chance Rick critic tell us what happens
next so Deb will befriends an angry
awkward over a 14-year old boy and I
mean how specific come on the boy's name
is Russell and he's a mutant at a
hospital where they mistreat kids they
did terrible things to mean they're
things that literally scarred me for
life note we are aware this accent is
terrible Tim was only exposed to New
Zealand with an interview she saw what
peer checks and about the Hobbit movies
we're sincerely sorry to all of New
Zealand for this outrage both the accent
and The Hobbit movies I know what you're
saying kid they took something away from
you they hurt you and you want to hurt
them back I get it because you were
amazing in the hunt for the Willard
people and both you and sam neill
deserve an oscar actually that does
bring up a good point I know I was also
in that right no I mean the tone these
movies create the fourth wall jokes are
funny but do they get in the way of the
heavier scenes however these films try
to have actual substance to them and
work in dramatic elements but it's a
little jarring to be winking to the
camera when in the following scene
you're talking about child abuse does it
work to follow the corpses of family
members with jokes about how many x-men
were paid to be in the film
well I'm sorry have you ever seen a
Marvel movie like any of them yeah it's
basically a bunch of dramatic moments
followed by jokes hey what do we say I'm
the only fourth wall breaker remember
yeah why is that so you can want to be
me when you sneak into these films that
manipulative or genius yes to which yes
but this isn't the fourth wall humor so
drastically different from this kind of
drama that's something this big isn't
gonna fit I hate to look Walter White do
you laugh when we tell the jokes yeah do
you feel emotion at the emotional
moments I guess it's because we give
them time to slowly ease them in tell me
that was totally in tension
that's why I can go into shooting people
that hurt him like this whoo can I shoot
that any understates gun laws probably
but the spells bad news for our wacky
fourth wall breaking superhero dressed
in red I'm in the field now this oh yeah
I forgot to mention I use my portal gun
to bring another self-aware characters
to emphasize how original you are you
won't break the fourth wall literally
breaking is it too late to review show
dogs hey you talking to the camera I
like doing that too today we'd like to
talk about the Avengers of hey man hey
hey man okay there's only room for one
Jedi Master of obscure non sequiturs
this review clearly has no budget so
we'll just cast you as Colossus okay I
teach the kids Russia but the current
president that's a good idea
well what do I do now well you not mean
the kid out for killing those people and
Han man do it I'm already sick of you
I'm just giving it right the hell out of
nowhere a character from a dystopian
future ceases Kentucky Fried family and
journeys back in time because Russell is
the one who killed them now in a movie
this is just rollin playing cable but
truth be told we don't have anyone quite
as awesome as that so we went for the
next best thing
I am cable Boehner I take it I have to
watch the show to know if this is he's a
reoccurring character yeah I have to
stop that boy from performing a terrible
crime of child murder who by performing
child murder
can't meet a local calls that malko
palace no like they said earlier
Lonergan a to pick him off
we're just hitting the ground really
hard
look Bobo if we're gonna make you
marketable the future franchises you
cannot tone down the kid killing my only
concern is if Disney Vice Box what they
gonna do when cable fights Panos now
that's not true Disney's merger wouldn't
necessarily affect Fox's cinematic
releases enough for the fourth wall
breaking dr. Bunsen so if my beaker you
knock off novelty dog shit let's blow I
thought you'd like that
okay I need a man to catch my breath so
go to hell if you have a blocker cuz
you're cutting my time in half
[Applause]
[Music]
so typical decides to recruit a team
with his best friend played by TJ Miller
yeah we made that joke too as he goes
through a lineup of wacky characters my
name is Woody Allen hey audience don't
you wish your life was like this hey
what did I say
only I talked to the viewer oh hey
everybody my site the street merchants
in the opening or not there's nobody
hearing me this is the most embarrassing
day of my life full moon why did dr.
Katz come in D frog here no I am NOT
being upstaged by a sock oh come on
that's Kermit the Frog man he's a
goddamn sock watch oh gosh Jesus I don't
know Eric haven't you got far enough
with the fourth wall breakers not until
he sees a little well I can keep Mickey
hack he is your other half give a little
pop culture spewing pimp hey at least I
mock the convention of lame catchphrases
well the love a Love Boat whatever hey
how many pickle Ric shirts did you sell
today I was Petty and beneath you
excuse me oh great and what show are you
from Atlanta what does that matter do
they look at the camera in Atlanta
they're not supposed to great tell me
about yourself I'm Domino and my
superpower isn't always looking yeah I
saw that episode of ducktales - it's not
a power
it's terazzo is prove it I was in Geo
storm and yet I have a role in Deadpool
- you're hired
he calls his team x47 looks like he
shall call them the Expendables because
they all die before he's been starting
their first mission it looks like it's
just you and me Kermit Domino also
survived using her luck in they head off
to save Russell and an exciting car
chase wait a minute a car chase yeah
with this reviews budget you're gonna do
a car chase well attempt to screw it
we're gonna do a car chase with no money
we're gonna do it my way
what the hell is your way
[Music]
I'm so confused you know I just work me
we all know what's coming thing is our
original car chase was even lamer they
go to save Russell but he's turned more
angry than ever especially having teamed
up with one of his cellmates you gonna
harm me there's no one I can't kill dip
oh wow
seriously we're gonna go with that one
you can reference it in the movie and
first of all it's ten goddamn years old
what classic never dies no matter how
dumb it is second I'm really trying to
distance myself from x-men 3
x-men 3 your x-men originals yes yes
well this is my review and that's the
version I watch Russell
I'm sorry more people don't know about
the wilderness family in the future he
won't have to kill you actually that
sounds reasonable right we should have
done that before
hell no I'm gonna be the little sister
to his big daddy that sounded bad right
very bad and I'm gonna kill the
scientists that torture me starting my
reign of terror juggernaut
meet him to death oh I've suffered
enough from that thank you very much so
she decides to join the team to see if
they can talk Russell out of his evil
ways in Soviet Russia fourth wall breaks
you knock it off Don Cheadle's Captain
Planet what the hell are you doing here
you only have two lights the girlfriend
is dead in my New Zealand accent sucks
I'm taking what I can get
fair enough let's make up for the shitty
Dark Phoenix movie we know we're gonna
get
export skills the shit out of the
scientists that torture the young
mutants right before teaching a young
mutant that's wrong to kill the
scientist Russell I know you think
revenge will make you feel better
especially because I've gotten revenge
on like a million people and by god it
felt great what is the moral of this
movie again no idea but killing him
won't fix anything it'll just turn you
into a super villain super villain with
the name Russell and that's just
uncomfortably weird let's talk to you
more shooting no I have a collar on so
I'll die for him oh yeah that's gonna
happen yeah kill the franchise yeah sure
my god you sacrificed yourself for me
that's right and now I'm finally going
to die ending my misery
I totally a.m. I even said in the
beginning I was gonna die we're
following through yeah only comic book
movies had loopholes yeah this is really
bad
hey you want your family back or what oh
I'll miss you too
no from this day forward I will never
harm another human being and hope that
fate will do my daddy work for me
so Deadpool is reunited with his love
which is kind of strange the x-men
movies are confirming there's an
afterlife well at least there's not a
help yeah if there was it would just be
the hit man's body got on a continuous
loop but it's saved by cables final
attempt that time travel yeah I saved ya
even though you obviously wanted to die
keeping the collar on so I guess you
stopped the suicide which I guess he
could just do again but he seems happy
now yeah raising your kid that you're
not really raising I stopped trying to
make sense of this I gave up medicine
and let's go start x-force you in cable
well I did dedicate my life to saving my
family but they seem to be okay now
that's true I suppose nothing bad can
happen to him in apocalyptic future sure
why not
so it turns out this was a bleep bitch
but Deadpool ends the film by stealing
cables time-traveling device and saving
Vanessa in the past you saved me
stopping everything from happening
including x-force did I though
did I I don't know did you well we'll
see what hits we are doing an x-force
movie so we'll see who's popular and
who's worth keeping ah seeing who's the
Natalie Portman of Oh Thor films
we're keeping our options open not a bad
idea so that was Deadpool 2 and it was
with a helping of picks trick you know
I've had it up to here doc you're fine
it doesn't matter how big you are you're
still the family guy in a spider-man
costume well you're still Futurama with
It's Always Sunny writers you're both
right
but that doesn't make it any less good
or unique Deadpool is doing what many
have done before but it's doing it in a
new and extreme way there aren't that
many mediums that blend in tense
dramatic moments with goofy self-aware
humor it's usually seen as two totally
jarring but the fact is the fourth wall
jokes make the characters even easier to
like so we care for them even more when
they're going through the dramatic
moments and on the flip side the jokes
seem even funnier when they interrupt a
legit emotional moment so what reactions
seem more magnified than usual it's like
a Disney character dying it's a cartoon
and it's goofy but it still appeals to
our inner child making us connect to
them in a unique way so when something
bad does happen to them we feel it even
more even with the movie cliches they've
been done a million times
they still combine what's simple and
familiar with what's complex and new for
example did you realize there's no real
villain in this movie yeah none of the
main characters are bad guys they're
just people with disagreements how often
do you see a superhero movie like that
do you also realize how much money went
into what's essentially troll humor half
the time those kind of jokes do not get
a budget this big these are familiar
elements being combined to give us
something unique and yes every fanbase
has a small percent that's too obsessive
yeah by the way I missed the old colored
wall how dare you fight the Angry Video
Game Nerd in that totally real phew well
played but that doesn't mean the
majority of viewers aren't smart open
funny people looking for both a good
time with a bit of depth the Deadpool
movies are worthy of their attention and
the mixing of two totally different
genres both done well makes them a very
different and enjoyable new experience
we've seen these elements before but not
together in this way and as long as they
keep finding new things to add to them
my guess is these movies will be
celebrated for quite a lot
that's that same old middle-of-the-road
bullshit you always pull ha ya nut up
and pick a side yeah yeah that's one
thing we can agree on this guy's a pussy
mr. participation award over here you
know you guys are funny in media but
you're assholes in real life yeah don't
act like it doesn't get you hard here's
the spine of a red twizzler and he still
has more backbone than you come on let's
go make some jokes to piss off some
sjw's The Wall Street Journal never mind
him he's dyslexic does that mean I need
insulin you were a mistake Morty
I'm the Nostalgia Critic end just
because a funny jerk on TV can get away
with it doesn't mean yeah dicks rule
Jesus Christ not anymore we bleed him
out of existence last week
[Music]
[Applause]
you
hi you might have noticed at the end of
Deadpool - there was no after credits
sequence wasting the time of millions of
pissed-off fans so this one's for you
this isn't that good - warmer kind of
sucks
is it too late to review show dogs
hey guys Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out and this week we are
doing kids ranked and this actually ties
into a new video series we're doing
called what you can do that demonstrates
what you can do if you don't have money
to donate but you can actually go and
volunteer at some of these local
charities we're going to show you a
snippet from that show here only about
three minutes but we highly recommend
you see the whole video because this is
a wonderful organization they do
incredible work definitely donate or if
you knew the area volunteer just do what
you can to show your support for them my
name is Kelsey Liverpool and I am the
co-founder and executive director for
kids ranked our program designed
specifically for military children our
pillars are connected and served we want
the kids to connect with each other to
work on leadership which a lot of them
innately have and then to be a service
to their communities and what is it that
you're going to be doing today today I'm
excited we're at Fort Sheridan Cemetery
former Army Post and we're going to be
placing flags from Memorial Day in
preparation for their Memorial Day
ceremony it's about remembering a lot of
our service members are forgotten and so
this is a way of acknowledging who they
were and that they sacrificed their
lives when I came in which was around
1970 at that point people hated Vietnam
couldn't take it out on the government
says they took it out on the military
people signs up dogs and sailors stay
off the law and stuff like that so when
I sees things like this and the military
is now held in high regard the flags
mean that somebody is remembered I'm
Kristen Skinner I'm a
lieutenant commander in the Navy I'm a
nurse we've been a part of it since 2015
and have loved it and we've loved having
the community love us and embrace us and
then we love to like give back so we've
done some stuff at the VA with the
Ronald McDonald House bringing flowers
to the vets at Louisville so we've
explained to the kids that no Memorial
Day isn't for us they wear the uniform
as far as sort of given the ultimate
sacrifice so we can all barbecue and
have our freedoms in America we like to
add authentic military kind of tones and
culture to the work that we do and
service is such a big part of it so
their parents serve the country we want
the kids to serve their communities and
understand that it's not that something
that everybody does but it's a it's a
really positive way to get them out of
themselves and sometimes when you move
you become isolated
we are strength based I don't want them
to feel sorry for themselves or feel
like it's something that's a burden we
want them to feel that they're empowered
by it this year alone we volunteered for
15 different organizations or have done
15 different service projects one of our
pride members had a cousin with cancer
and she wanted to do a drive to collect
toys for children with cancer so we did
that as a group of homeless shelter
where we go and and help prep for a
service night you know to feed meals
somebody came to me and was looking for
a way to give back to military children
and they wanted to do like school
supplies which is really great but I
felt like we needed to do something that
was addressed in need for our kids so we
partnered with the Highland Park High
School Rotary Club and we put together
welcome and farewell kits for military
children we had a young man that moved
to Japan and I asked him you know are
you excited to go to Japan you know your
friends gonna miss you and he said
nobody's gonna even know I'm God oh wow
and that's devastating and we don't want
that for our kids we don't want them to
feel like they're invisible and that
nobody cared that they were here so
these welcome and farewell kids give us
bringing tension around you know
recognizing them adapting bravery
courage determination these are all
things that come
from being part of a military family
thank you so much definitely go check
out the site it's a wonderful site if
you can donate or volunteer they do so
much good definitely thank you so much
[Music]